en
fait moi c'est ma fille
chloé
je suis contente de t'avoir rencontré
merci de pas être comporter comme un
connard sèche c'est de faire au mieux
laisse moi deviner été clés sont dans
ton sac sinon je t'emmène sur une île
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je repars demain aux états unis ça va
pas te manquer tout ça
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est prête pour la coloc je suis prête
pour la collecte
puis ce qu'on embarque tout ce qu'il ya
là tout ce qui a
trait aux aguets une femme aussi sexy
j'en ai jamais connu vous voulez faire
partie de la famille de chloé
[Applaudissements]
c'est un lien avec un bon général il
repart avec une fille là il arrive avec
une
on en apprendrait ce que tu veux les
gens changent
[Musique]
c'est encore les sens mais ça se passe
plutôt bien
[Musique]
théo gueule que quand tu détruis ce que
tu fais micky mais plus même homme qui à
6h micky est un bébé
c'est un petit garçon
je suis sûr que tu crèves envie de
[ __ ] en l'air parce que ça se passe
bien
elle thème cette fille tu es super bien
avec elle
une belle histoire d'amour romantique
tu as eu un vrai coup de foudre
tu crois pas si bien dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]